- [Instructor] We are
told there are 10 students
in the poetry club.
This week, each student wrote two poems.
What does the expression
10 times two represent
and they give us some choices.
Pause this video and see
if you can work that out.
All right, so there are 10 students
in the poetry club and each
student wrote two poems.
So I would use 10 times
two to figure out, hey,
for each of those 10
students, if they each wrote
two poems, then we have
10 times two total poems.
And if we look at the
choices, that is choice C
right over here.
If we look at choice A,
the number of students,
the number of students is 10.
It wouldn't be 10 times two.
And then the number of
poems each student wrote,
well, that's the second
piece of information.
They each wrote two poems.
That wouldn't be 10 times two either.
Let's do another one
of these, a little bit
different this time.
So now we're asked, let me scroll this
over a little bit, which
problem can we solve
with three times eight?
So pause this video and have a go at it
before we do it together.
All right, now let's read these and see
if you can solve it
with three times eight.
Ellen has eight pieces of gum.
Fair enough.
She ate three pieces at school.
Hope she didn't swallow the gum.
That could be problematic.
How many pieces of gum
does Ellen have left?
So would you use multiplication for that?
The way I would tackle
it, if she has eight
pieces of gum and if she ate three
and we wanna figure out how much gum does
she have left, I'm assuming
outside of her body,
well then I would
subtract three from eight.
I wouldn't multiply eight by three.
So I would rule this one out.
That's not going to be my choice.
I'm not going to solve this problem
with multiplication or at
least by three times eight.
Brendon has eight t-shirts.
Fair enough.
That's about how many I have.
He goes to the store to
buy three more t-shirts.
How many t-shirts does he have now?
Would I solve that with multiplication?
Well, let's see.
The way I would solve it
is he has eight shirts
and then he's buying three more.
I would add three to
figure out how many total
t-shirts he has.
I wouldn't multiply by three.
So I'd rule that out.
So let's see how choice C is looking.
There are eight chocolates in each box.
Mike has three boxes of chocolates.
How many chocolates are there?
So this is interesting.
So he has three boxes of chocolates.
So let me draw those boxes.
One box, two box, three
boxes of chocolate.
And each of 'em have eight chocolates.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
Well, yeah, if I wanna figure out how many
total chocolates there are,
I have three groups of eight.
I would solve that by
multiplying three times eight.
So I like this choice a lot.
Let's do another example.
Here we are told Gerald is going to plant
a garden this spring.
That's a good thing to be doing.
He plans to have seven plants in each row.
There will be eight rows.
Which expression can Gerald
use to find the total
number of plants needed for his garden?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, I'll do a
little bit of a drawing.
I'll do it in green
'cause we're talking about
rows of plants.
So seven plants in each row
and there will be eight rows.
So one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
Seven plants in each row.
And then we're going to have eight rows.
So let me copy and paste that.
So that's two rows.
That's three rows.
That is four rows.
Getting there.
Five rows.
Six rows.
Seven rows.
And eight rows.
So we don't have to actually calculate it
but the way you could think about it
is you have seven plants in each row
and then you have eight rows of plants.
Eight rows of plants.
So if you wanna figure
out the total amount
you would multiply eight times seven.
And so let's see, that's this first choice
right over here.
You wouldn't multiply eight
times seven times seven.
And eight plus seven
is definitely not going
to give you the total
number of plants here.
So yeah, we like using
the eight times seven.
And we're done.